greetings and salutations
welcome to the very first down the
middle that is going to be a little bit
less economics a little bit less finance
and a little bit more
life
a little bit more philosophy a little
bit more philanthropy
a little bit more what we've taken away
as life's lessons
when we have great mentors
enter our lives with that i would like
to introduce you to none other than
david kotak chairman and chief
investment officer of cumberland
advisors david thank you so much for
being with me today
always a pleasure to be with you and i'm
delighted that your haberdasher and my
haberdasher were able to coordinate
isn't it wonderful imagine they didn't
and they didn't even tell us it's
remarkable and i wore the hair on top of
the head and you wore the beard so this
is good
there you go it was uh serendipitous all
the way around
um so today we're going to talk about
about fishing
we're going to talk about
the genesis
of an event
that has become a meaningful aspect
of so many people's lives
uh so many of my cl dear friends
uh but why don't you take us all the way
back in time
to what first interested you in fishing
itself
oh my gosh
you're asking me to go back over 70
years i am
yes well i caught my first fish when i
was probably four or five
and i went fishing with my father
who taught me a little bit about it
and
[Music]
it was so much fun i've been doing it
ever since
so that's how it all started as a little
boy fishing with his father
and
in the interest of time maybe you can go
over the high points in terms of where
you have fished in this world
oh my
well i i've spent a lot of time in some
very exotic and wonderful places
i think i have 17 or 18 trips to
patagonia some number like that
close to 20. i don't think it's actually
something like that
so argentina and chile are exciting
places
certainly all over
north america
and
i guess the most exciting
single fishing day was fishing and
catching actually because they're two
separate things you know
people like to think
they're catching
when they go fishing it isn't so
one has little to do with the other and
the more fishing you do the more
catching is
less and less important
but i did take one trip to the zambezi
river
and
do a very exotic safari i had to carry
240 pounds of gear for one day
it was like the famous fishing shows
that you see where they carry all the
stuff and they go all the sort of stuff
i was able to do that once
and actually catch a tiger fish
on the zambezi river
and that was a very exciting and very
expensive fish
[Laughter]
um at some point
though actually
take take me back since we're way back
in time take me back to
how cumberland advisors came about when
it came about where it came about
oh my gosh
48 years ago it was founded i had a
partner who's no longer with us
uh i was solo before that i this was
i got out of the army 1969.
uh those are dates that wouldn't be in
your
current memory uh you you may have read
about them
and um
we formed cumberland advisors he was in
new york at the time with hutton he was
managing an office in manhattan he
didn't like the direction of the
industry
and the two of us decided we would
launch a firm with no conflicts of
interest
sell no product render advice fee for
service only take no custody
try to be a pure advisor
now this is a while ago
and in those days there wasn't much of
that and we didn't like the motivation
of people to sell product for commission
and
render that sale in the context
of independent advice
i'll give you an example
the life insurance salesman calls you on
the phone and says danielle
you don't need life insurance it's not
necessary for you or your family i
recommend you do not buy it and
therefore i don't want you to buy life
insurance from me
how many such telephone calls have you
ever received zero
exactly so what we wanted to do was
take independent fifa service
in its purest sense
and fully transparent structure
and that's how we form cumberland
advisors in 1973.
remarkable history david um
so
take us forward at some point
you came to a place called grand lake
stream maine
what year was that
and how many were there
well i know you're going to ask me that
question when was the first time so i
went up with my son
33 years ago the two of us and a guy
we stayed at a place called wetherbees
we'd never been there
weatherby's are still there uh the
original owners sold it and they're not
there nice folks there was a
transitional
event which is why we're not at
weatherby's now we've moved around and
we've been in liens lodge for a long
time as you know
and we went to a remote place so we
could bond a little fish a little and be
father-son
that was 33 years ago my son is 46.
now
uh
an excellent fly fisherman likes to
stand next to me on the dock
and make sure that he throws 20 feet
longer than i do in a straight line
but that's the way it is i look at him
and i smile and i say next week try 30 i
hope you get it so that's how we do
that was the first ship that was not
camp coat time that was going out in the
woods to a remote place
and fishing and that happened a few more
times
with one or two others
and then it became
three or four or five people depending
on which year
and think of it as hey a couple of guys
on a fishing trip going out in the woods
in me
and
the evolution of who
was included or who came or who wanted
to come
gravitated to economics financial
markets geopolitics serious thought
let's not just go out in the woods and
drink and eat fish
and tell jokes
let's have some
deep conversation
in ways in which
we can explore an idea
along came
and as you well know
that changed everything
why
because people that you and i know now
i'll give you an example harvey
rosenblue
you know harvey harvey was a mentor for
you may still be
harvey introduced us
more years ago than i think
any of the three of us including rvu and
me want to count
so what did harvey do
after saying no to me for a few years he
and i survived 9 11 we were at the same
meeting in new york
and
he said you know something
i want to go with you next year
another guy
stu hoffman you know stew
same thing
so
camp kotak really started
after 9 11 when it got bigger
because of people who said yes instead
of no
and of course what happened is they
found a place as
you now know from your own experiences
where you can
in depth
have conversation not agreement
necessarily we you and i have witnessed
all kinds of disagreements up there
but you can have them civilly
and
you make friends with
folks and you in
you you enlarge your network of
informational exchange and thinking and
i have found in in the last quarter
century of doing this
so from 9 11 that's 20 years
and the few times before 9 11 when it
wasn't just
me and one other person going fishing
i
always have a takeaway
of something new
and if you go somewhere anywhere any
kind of meeting conference gathering
anywhere
and you take one little speck away
that's a new thought it's worth it
i had that conversation with you the
first time we met
at a richmond fed meeting i think it was
i think it was richmond was it richmond
meeting it was indeed
yeah
so
that's how it's evolved and of course
then the name camp kotak i didn't
originate the name
that that's another matter
i was up there
cnbc at the time i was a contributor for
cnbc so i had a contract with them cnbc
was covering it steve liesman
came
and he's interviewing me on the
dock
and becky quick
puts or the producer that was doing the
show
puts camp kotak
in the
banner underneath the image
and becky quick says cam kotak that's a
good name for it
so we really owe becky quick thank you
for the name
so
as the bird flies
is one matter uh as somebody who lives
in dallas texas
uh it's waking at oh dark 30
flying from dfw into philadelphia flying
from philadelphia into bangor maine and
driving three hours northeast to the
canadian border and stopping for the
best lobster roll in the world on the
way
um
how are it's a good thing it's a good
thing you like the lobster roll
i do i mean well so and explain a little
bit about what camp kotalk is for the
uninitiated oh oh and i must go back
david i was one of the inaugural eight
women
what was that like
why were let me do that one
yeah let me let me do women first okay
it was impossible
to get a woman
women
to come
what go out in the woods what mosquitoes
what
you know
i asked and invited and invited and
invited
and got turned down and turned down
nicely
and there was a whole debate about this
because there was this whole
circulating image that this is boys only
like the club that used to be in
california the political group and all
that stuff i said no it's not we can't
get women to come here they won't come
my friends in financial markets and
economics they won't come
for one reason or another always say
thank you maybe next year and always
have
some event some reason but say no
i invited diane swank
a dozen times
each time she thanked me
but didn't come ellen used cromwell
didn't come
i invited her this year
i said i know your answer before i asked
you
she didn't come
but finally we we broke through that
and now that's not an issue nobody cares
so that that was a history it was
i i'm glad that it
changed
but that's me
i don't need a boys club in the woods
and frankly that would be boring
so this is a much better
structure
so in the answer to the women evolution
that's how it happened
now what was the other it helps to have
a great roommate though so
of course it does well i know who your
roommate was the two of you became fast
friends at once and still are we're
roommates again this year i can
guarantee you
i understand i've been warmed
warned so for the uninitiated after they
finally make their way
there if you were a guide if you were
the president of camp code talk oh wait
you are
but if you were to if you were to ask
somebody how to prepare
for
three solid days of fishing and by the
way don't come if you don't want to fish
you learn that very quickly but how
would you tell somebody to prepare for
for three days of fishing in grand lake
stream maine what should they pack
well okay what should you pack well
first of all this is very casual so this
is jeans this is outdoors this is a
think of it as a camp for adults you
have hot water and clean sheets
you know the the accommodations are
rustic but pleasant much good food we
all gain weight
but that's
so it's not you're not living in a pup
tent
as as you well know
you i would disagree with you on one
thing
fishing and fishing skills are
irrelevant
and as you know the guide will teach you
what to do
the guy will catch the fish for you
absolutely no no i i will i will never i
had been deep sea fishing before i came
to maine
and you are i i'm in complete agreement
with you david you don't need to know
how to fish it's not that it's the
experience of fishing there was i'll
never forget an afternoon i sat in a
canoe with jim bianco
and we debated for three hours why
stanley fisher would be coming out of
retirement to become vice chair of the
federal reserve
while we fished and caught a lot of fish
and had a i mean it's one of those
one of the best memories of my life but
i still don't know everything that i
needed to pack because boy do i
i check more baggage when i'm coming to
maine than any other trip even if i'm
going to europe for two weeks
i see i only bring a toothbrush and a
pair of socks
what do you need you need rain gear
because sometimes you can get caught in
the rain
that happens everywhere but it happens
there too
and you need a light jacket and you need
a hat we give you a hat with your name
on it
um
and you need a couple pairs of jeans or
fishing pants you do not need fishing
gear guides provided for you if you
don't have it if you have it and you're
serious fisherman i mean for me
at leans lodge i keep six rods and an
entire gear bag i really then they'll do
that for two reasons
number one depending on where i'm going
to fish and how i'm going to fish that
becomes important
number two
we lost a very good friend as you know
jack rivkin
jack was a serious
fly fisherman
so when he came up he didn't bring a
gear bag
well i don't blame him he said to me do
i need a gear bag i said no you don't
need your bag i mean who wants to carry
a 40 pound gear bag and do all the
flights and travel that you just
described it's a pain
in the neck
literally when you carry it and
metaphorically elsewhere
so
i had a rod and reel
and i said jack i've got an extra rod
reel i can fix europe
so i stopped to be able to do that
and do that every year with someone
so
that's what i keep up there but a person
doesn't need to bring any equipment
they can if they want to
and some do
and they
need two pairs of jeans and a shirt
or
cover-up but if they want to change
and you're you're one of the ones who
likes to change for
dinner i wear the same pair of shorts
and i wear bedroom slippers from the
cabin to the lodge
and eat dinner
which is a wonderful gathering of we
have guests and we have comments and
you've participated in that so you know
and
this coming year we've got two weekends
because we divided the group
because of covet we're but we're full
and we have terrific commentary you know
in
the the
program if you will
it's a discussion
followed by all of us involved in an
informal discussion there's no
powerpoint there are no slides
there's no screen i remember when robini
came one time
and nouriel comes up and he says what do
i wear i said jeans
well that was okay i said this is a
casual place can't be mean
okay so he comes up and he's got a
memory stick
and he he says where do i put the memory
stick
i said you could put it on the end of
your hook but you won't catch anything
i said you what do you do with that he
says well i got some slides i said
nouriel i told you there's no slides
this is not any one of the 30 people 40
50 people
can give
speeches and lectures and present slides
that's not what this is about
you didn't need to go through all the
travel
to come here for that purpose and i
chris whalen was with me we we had
briefed him and everything meanwhile
he got upset with me because he brought
a memory stick and he had to take it
home
but meanwhile that happened to be no no
wait wait you're getting save that you
know where i'm going
david save that please save that
um it's your time let's do it your way
okay well we're going to come to that
because it's a pretty
momentous event that we have coming up
to us it's a 10-year anniversary type of
event but first
uh let's just say that the people
watching and listening today have no
idea what a chatham house rule is
okay so chatham house said there are
actually two rules that apply
at camp kotak the jackson hole rule and
the chatham house rule so chatham house
rule says something like this
you can
articulate publicly in something you
write or something you say to any forum
you want
the takeaway of the group
but you cannot quote anyone without
their permission
if they and most of the people as you
know say yes sure i don't care you can
quote me but that's their choice not
the one who is the journalist or writer
or
other person
covering things
so the chatham house rule is takeaway of
the group
is public
individual quotation and citation
requires permission first
essentially that's what it is
the jackson hole rule is a little
different okay
well the jackson hole rule which erased
from the meeting
in jackson hole
is
if you walk by a table
and two people are talking and you
happen to hear something in that
conversation that you weren't supposed
to hear
the jury is directed to disregard the
commentary
that's a jackson hole rule
now you know and i know
business deals get done up at
me
negotiations have happened mergers have
happened
launches of new
uh
securities uh introductions of people of
all types and some of those
conversations are susceptible
to eavesdropping
either unintentionally
or in some cases sadly
intentionally
if we find that out that person never
gets invited back
and as you know there have been a couple
of occasions
where there have been people who have
been asked not to return
and in two cases to leave
so the the
the trustworthiness of the gathering
is very important
and i think
my takeaway from having had 20 years of
this and hundreds of people
is that is rarely violated it is well
respected it's certainly well respected
by the people you and i know who voted
well i will say as as a veteran uh
that
it isn't it's an extraordinary
environment because
you speak more freely you think more
freely your mind is more open than it
otherwise otherwise would be because of
the discrete nature
of the gathering which makes it all the
more open
ironically
so it's hard to convey
the mastery
uh the nobility
the beauty of third fourth generation
guides and
but but talk about how camp kotak
has affected
this part of the country
uh that in many ways is more
impoverished and more rural than other
areas of the country that many people
would be familiar with especially the
people visiting
uh once a year when they attend camp
well
washington county maine
is one of the poorest counties east of
the mississippi
and it's
its character because it was really
dependent upon
a paper mill logging operation
which closed
and it was a one
industry
[Music]
regional
area
so when the paper mills in that business
went the way of evolution
hundreds and hundreds of incomes for the
region
dropped
so it's a poor
county
and
the fishing guides
uh
are are part of a community which have
been active
in i would say fishing is only part of
it hunting fishing outdoors
maine northern maine image
that's exactly
so
they are a culture
um
my view they are wonderful caring
real people
they follow from a distance the events
of the world
i think they like us because they like
to listen to the conversations maybe
inside they're laughing at us
but whatever the case may be
that's the structure
so we become friends with them as you
know i think you fish with j.r every
year we've done that for how many years
how many years have you fished with jr
every single time i've been how many
it's been more than ten years okay
yeah i'm sorry my fishing guide is a
full you know
unfortunately he just had a tragedy
we're trying to help him with a gofundme
account my fishing guide is ray saka
basin
ray is a full uh blood passama quadi
indian his
lineage in his tribe is a thousand years
old
his
ancestry goes back to the days of acacia
back to the days of the what we would we
call the french indian war but it was
really french and british and the
indians were used the tribes all four of
them were used as pawns by both sides
the passim aquatics at one point fought
on the british side at one point fought
on the french side
and
both sides
didn't care about the people who were
fighting for them
so the history is quite a remarkable
piece of the region unfortunately
in american
education these days the history that
history of that region and acacia
the f that evolution has sort of dropped
out of the history books so but it's
there and it's there in real terms when
you tour it around
and look at it
so i you know it's it's a very neat kind
of place the other thing
that i would suggest for
people who are listening or
to this interview
is that the pasamaquati indian
reservation land which is a very large
tract
and by the way it's an equally large
tract on the canadian side of the border
there's actually four
pieces to password party
region two on the canadian side and two
where we are and where we fish is just
one of the two we we don't go to the
other ones 40 miles away
so you you you look at the history and
you say here's this large tract
of tribal land
it doesn't change
it doesn't get a new hotel
it doesn't get developed it has a set of
rules and the tribe governs the rules
adjacent to it
is another two or three hundred thousand
acres of land trust
which was part of a master settlement of
paper mill companies and logging and so
forth
and
as you know when you stand on the deck
of leans lodge
and look at a sunset
on your left
is all this land trust
and in the back and on the right
is all this reservation land and i have
been standing on that deck for probably
a quarter century or close to it not one
new house
is built on that shoreline
the only buildings on the shoreline
occupy the camp sites or house sites
that preceded
the land trust
and the reservation land
you know david so it's pristine
yep and it's not going to change so i
i've stopped on a few of those uh when
when there wasn't time to get to lunch
just to borrow an outhouse or two over
the years uh j.r knows where all the
cleanest ones are and that's a good
guide
yes it is let's talk about something
important so uh
let's just say i was to bring a case of
two buck chuck
from trader joe's would i ever get
invited back and by the way while we're
on the subject of wine why don't you
walk us through a rookie's lunch and
experience
and tell us what the role the wives play
just let let's have lunch on camp code
talk
well okay i don't know about the
particular vintage of tupac chuck
that's that one i'm it's not in my radar
screen
but
you know we've developed a tradition of
fine wines libations some people bring
other things
i remember martin barnes
coming up
and bringing some wonderful old
seasoned delicious three drop at a time
uh single malt scotch
the scotsman yes
yes and he put him on a table
and he said if you can't name correctly
i'll let you have one
and it was wonderful so it's not just
wine but the tradition is wine
most people
bring case or ship a half a case for
taste we share
and we taste and compare
and we do that
tonight dinner for those who wish
so lunch can be an interesting affair
you think about this you get up at 6 or
6 30 or so in the morning or 5 30 or 6
depending on whether you're an early
riser by the time we're in the
dining hall at 6 30 in the morning
there's half a dozen left laptops that
are busy i always think of barry
ritholtz i don't know he must get up at
4 a.m to get there before anybody else i
don't know
so
there's a lot of activity breakfast we
pair up
we have fishing guides we organize
ourselves the fishing guides and the
cooking guides in the lodge have already
started the process to greet us with a
sumptuous outdoor
shore lunch which is cooked by them and
if we bring in fresh fish they cook it
on the spot once you do that you won't
eat frozen fish anymore you learn
what fish are supposed to taste like
and
those lunches can go a couple hours
they're great discussions we have guests
we've had the consul general of the
region from canada stop and say hello
at different times we have different
special guests
and they may visit at lunch say a few
words and
greetings and mix and talk with people
or we may do the same thing at dinner as
you know we've had governors and
senators and congressmen and
federal reserve officials and foreign
officials and people from all over the
world
so that that's how the meals work the
lunches are all outdoors they're a
different lunch site
every day
the gathering
and fishing terrain is a different
location every day so it's diverse it's
not going back to the same pond three
days in a row
and that's the experience
i don't know of anyone who has ever said
it's not fun
i do know two people
who
i will call them
those who fish by going to zay bars and
buying some smoked salmon and call it
fishing and they want to stay on central
park because they want to walk in the
park and that's their experience with
the outdoors
we had two like that that's okay you're
allowed
and
they said i'm not coming back here
because it's it's not a ritz-carlton
and i said well that's a matter of
choice but i'm very happy you
came once and enjoyed the experience
or you can learn to pack everything you
possibly need which we do learn how to
do as the years go by you can adapt camp
kotak to your needs i can tell you that
there's an entire section of my closet
that is dedicated to high heel wedges
i'm very vertically challenged and i've
learned one of the first lessons i took
away from camp kotak not that any man
needs this is that you cannot wear high
heels but wedges will take you all the
way through the night with the height
most people think you are that was a
that was just an aside david
um
so uh
roubini i happened to be on my first and
last float plane
ride in and out of uh out of grand lake
stream i got a little nauseous i did see
a moose
uh and i sat right behind roubini who
happened to be
on a no carb and no alcohol diet at the
time
his timing was poor
his timing was poor but as far as
bloomberg was concerned his his presence
there
uh was auspicious tell us about
the friday
of august the 5th
2011. the
the
satellite
packed up and it was ready to go
well 10 years ago
bloomberg had broadcasts from the camp
they had finished for the day
people in the afternoon it was a friday
afternoon people were
either taking naps or they were out
fishing or out doing things or whatever
and somebody pulled a car in
and parked in a way
that wedged the tv truck
it was a live truck shut down
but it couldn't get out because it
couldn't turn around to get out so the
guys were stuck there because they
we didn't know whose car was couldn't
find somebody to move the car they might
have been out on a boat who knows
and
there was they were stuck in fact there
was a discussion i said you stay for
dinner that's all you know you can't get
out of here you might as well enjoy
yourself well the u.s gets downgraded by
standard force that was on a friday
after the close
most of financial television and
financial news had shut down for the
weekend
mike mckee
gets a call from new york
where's that truck
we can't find it
we want it back the u.s has just been
downgraded
and
bloomberg and new york thought the truck
was about two hours drive away from the
lodge
and that i don't know if you knew this
oh no and they were trying
no so so they were trying to find the
truck
which was shut off parked right outside
the lodge
and they were trying to find the truck
to get them to turn around and come back
because here you've got this cadre of
people that you could interview and
we've just had this remarkable event
so one thing leads to another fast
answer to the producer was the trucks
outside fire it up
and bloomberg broadcast live from camco
talk for five hours that night they went
on into i don't know 10 11 o'clock at
night before they shut it off
and
i think they were the only ones lives
with
uh
people and an interview roubini was one
of them
and mckee you know had a whole gang so
he had a field day
it was
again
there was no uh conspiracy here no plan
nothing it happened by accident
but
things like that happen in the woods in
maine accidents happen and sometimes
they're good ones
so um so back in maine uh
s p back then they were concerned that
the u.s had not addressed
its entitlement spending which was run
away and the u.s had not properly
addressed tax policy
either and those are the two main
reasons for the downgrade
and at last check uh
there will be yet another
debt limit that's approaching as camp
kotak is opening up for week one
well this is true
i would say if you examine the history
of the united states
and we maybe start with hamilton
i i would dismiss the early history of
the continental dollar which was a
hyperinflated currency and start anew
with the constitutional period
you could say we've always had a debt
limit
and we've always had a debt problem
and we've never been out of debt
although i think we came close with
hamilton but not
not to zero
and probably
we always will have
that's the nature of our system
as long as we borrow
denominated in our own currency
which we do
and as long as the world permits us
to maintain the world reserve currency
status
which so far it has
then i don't see the debt limit as an
issue except the one time
when newt gingrich was going to use it
and try to trigger a default
and in that one day
there was a slippage of so many basis
points i don't remember exactly now in
treasury yields on the threat that
congress would intentionally act
to
trigger a default that lasted hours not
even a full 24 hours so i'm not so
worried about the
issue it's ugly politics
and it's a game and a charade we all
know it
and it's a shame we have to have
it and have to put up with it
well i think that uh
i think that in the decade that's passed
we have seen a lot of ugliness in in
politics
um
we are a divided nation right now and i
would bring up the subject because it's
so near and dear to you and the work
that you've done
since the beginning of 2020
uh
on
not the emotion necessarily of the
pandemic of covet 19
but on how devastating it can be
economically
and you've recently published a piece
where the italian in me would say
you're going to the mattresses this is
the first time i've seen this in a
little while where you're going to
you're leaning a little bit more towards
cash
and your reasoning you can walk me
through this is that there are quite a
few unknowns
right now and covid's at the top of that
list
even though i think a lot of people
would suggest to you that the country's
moved on are they right
well
there are people in the country who are
celebrating it's over
and every once in a while one of them
gets sick
some of those who get sick at hospital
in the eyes
some of those who are hospitalized die
to me
that's not over
so
i'm not convinced i would say three to
five years from now we might declare
that the pandemic
has morphed into
an endemic
health problem
and then it'll be with us for a long
time but it'll be endemic
so if we really think about the three
phases
you have an epidemic we started there in
china
you become a pandemic
we're in it
and eventually
it becomes endemic there still exists
in the world
smallpox
there still exists in the world measles
right now they are endemic
they weren't
but right now they are now what's
happening unfortunately is that there's
a larger larger cohort of people who
don't understand
the risk of measles
so they're not taking precautions and
what do we see
meat soils is growing again
and what do we see as an outcome
sickness
poor health some death
so that's a cycle i
i wrote in the piece that was just
published
that we cannot change human behavior
our behavior is awful
and we evidence it in our governance and
in our system it's very sad for me
at this point in time
to look at the political divide in the
country danielle to see
how politics
has
overtaken communal concern for public
health when i was a kid i didn't grow up
that way
nobody asked me at the rotary club
picnic or at the hospital fair
or in in
in civic activities
are you a democrat or are you a
republican are you red are you blue
it didn't matter
when i was in the army in the 60s there
were a whole lot of people
that didn't want to be there we had a
draft
we made elections and choices
you didn't ask the guy next to you
are you a republican
oh
you're you're a socialist left-wing
liberal democrat and you're wearing a
uniform you can't fight alongside me
or vice versa
i
got off a call
two hours ago with a man i'm doing a
panel with at the rocky mountain
economic summit next week in teton
springs
and we are the covid panel we are the
the healthcare panel
and he's he's got a biotech company he's
got a few he
he looks at the
the structure of the virus and he says
there was some
intervention by science to make this
more virulent
natural viruses don't work this way
i have had others tell that to me
and that's the debate
we never will find out
a hundred percent
i think unless some revelation comes out
that would be a big surprise
so one side
our side says wuhan lab leak
you are experimenting with making these
things more vicious and you succeeded
and you had a leak
china size said no it wasn't us it was
you it was at fort detrick in maryland
and by the way how do you deny it your
own cdc shut down fort dietrich for
three months
because of leaks and
rigidity of rules not observed well if
you're an american how do you say you
can't say that didn't happen it did
happen
so my view is the the problem
in public health has become this too
much too much
doing this it's your fault no it's your
fault
and that got into our politics
and we lost our compass
the compass went spinning around it
couldn't find north or south
we were too busy doing this
too busy in the
in the fight of politics and governance
and power and geopolitics
and we didn't pay attention to public
health
and our agencies failed us read michael
lewis's book
he's reporting things that
we don't want to hear but it's true
we don't want to say
our cdc
screwed up 15 million
tests by doing something they never were
equipped to do
the system in the united states has
contractors with specifications
manufacture things
what was the cdc
doing saying we'll manufacture this
they don't know how to manufacture
anything
they're science studies examination
accumulation of data
the next thing
which should enrage america
we had 50 states doing 50 different
things
and we had governance in many of them
that failed i'm sad to say i live in
florida
i still don't understand the decision
except
politics
triumphed
over public health
public health lost
political power grab one
people died
that's the simple summation of covet in
the united states
and sadly in other places in the world
too
so this is very troubling and it isn't
over
sad
so david um you better bring you better
bring a gallon a two buck truck when you
come up
uh i i'd bring much better wine than
that and you know it
um
the beauty of camp kotak is that
i couldn't tell you the political
parties of
most of the campers at present and i'm
pleased to be able to say that you've
created a unique and special
place um
what
what are your
life lessons
what are what what are your takeaways
what's the moral of the story of of camp
code talk that you would convey
to
everybody who's ever attended to
everybody who's never been able to
attend and to future attendees
well i think we we have a quarter
century or so of evidence
that people of goodwill
can behave
civilly
can engage in
debate and discourse
take differing points of view
and not be in fisticuffs with each other
and have mutual respect
and do so by the way
in the same way that we can have a
gathering and we can have a good meal
and we can have a little music and we
can relax and we can find a pristine
place that hasn't been spoiled to do it
and that's a nice thing so my takeaway
is
um having sort of
evolved this thing over many many years
it's a nice thing we're uh we're
changing the legacy of it with the
global interdependence center with which
i know you're very familiar and a
supporter
so the gic is now going to do the
organizing and
the administration
cumberland advisors has agreed to that
it was a recommendation that
i may
because i said to my colleagues at
cumberland
either one of you has to replace me and
do this
and replace sharon prasant who has now
retired
or
we have to find another mechanism
and
none of them uh volunteered no hands
went up
[Laughter]
so i
i said okay how's this i can work this
out with the global interdependence
center let's try it for a year and see
if it works and if the structure works
then camp kotak can continue whether
there's a kotak or no botox separate
question
and
the the structure and discussion
and the value of it to a lot of people
can also be sustained they agree
we're
we support it of course and we're doing
so this year
and you know
i'm at a stage in life where things are
uncertain
will i be back
a year from now when i'm 79 it would be
nice
or 80.
i gotta tell you
we're going to celebrate and
an 80th birthday
this year
up there not mine
and we've got fishing guides danielle
who are 79 and 80.
so we also have a couple of young ones
not enough
so
i'm a believer that
all successions
and transitions happen
they happen one of two ways
either happen because you have some
succession plan some
structure you lay out a map and you
attempt to implement it
and
hopefully
successfully i'm doing that with
cumberland as i get older i've got more
and more key people you know them
and they take greater and greater roles
and i become an old guy who's a
troublemaker
that's the way it should be
so
the alternative
is not to do succession and transition
planning
and then you have it anyway but it's
abrupt
and sometimes chaotic
and damaging and painful
so our election is the former we're
trying to do that jill fernito
and her staff have done a superb job as
you know because you've dealt with them
this year i think they got it they know
what to do
the lodge has it
you know i say to myself i don't even
need to go
why should i go through all those
troubles and all those flights and all
the travel from bangor to the main woods
i've seen it why should i go
but this is going to go i decided i
should come back
so i can see you we should wear blue
together one time i'll coordinate one
more time i have one last
one last question for you since this is
being recorded
uh uh
i've managed to avoid
uh anything that has anything to do with
knives and eels
for more than a decade now can i please
get it
verbally that i'll never ever have to
touch an eel
i will uh take this request
under serious advisement but when it
comes to the
the ale skinning committee
you know it's it's
we don't have a dictatorship up there as
you well know we have to engage in
conversation but you have managed
to avoid it
so you have a good track record i do
indeed i plan on keeping it i can't wait
to see you i thank you
so much for bringing camp co-talk to the
rest of the world god bless i will see
you soon david
i hope so stay safe and careful and i'll
see you in me take care
bye bye
there's no comparing
uh anybody i've ever interviewed on down
the middle to david kotak
he is
he's an individual
without
without a parallel i hope you enjoyed
his wisdom
and his insights
and uh and if you're curious to see
other people's views who've attended
camp code talk you you can watch uh you
can watch david rosenberg or you can
watch peter bookfar you can watch john
musso these are great examples of camp
kotok veterans who you'd never know we
come together in the woods because once
we
part ways we all go off to our other day
jobs uh but thank you for spending a
little bit of time
uh going inside of a very special place
uh for those who know it and i look
forward to the next time thank you so
much this is danielle demartino booth
with down the middle
[Music]
you